[Music]
so one time
i got a tampon stuck inside of me and my
boyfriend had to fish it out
that's my secret
i increased my antidepressant meds
the other day and i was not ready for
the side effects
so while i was vacuuming i [ __ ] my pants
uh yeah that's it that's
that's the entire thing
[Music]
so right now i'm leading on two people
separately one guy and one girl because
i'm bi like that
and i didn't mean to do that but now i
am
and i've told each of them that i'm not
really talking to anyone else
so i have to figure out a way to resolve
that and go with one of them
kind of sucks but price you pay for
leaving people on i guess
[Music]
i thought about lying at work and saying
my dad is dead just so i can get a
couple of days off
he's alive i just really he's not in my
life and i
can't stand him just kind of want a
couple of stick days
i have lost over 140 pounds and whenever
anyone asks me how i did it i say hard
work but in reality i had a gastric
sleeve surgery to help me
my secret is i spent a year and a half
in a
abusive and toxic relationship and i
lost my self-confidence
and my self-image and i lost myself in
it and so i'm in the process of
rebuilding who i am and
who i define myself is and loving myself
i hate being touched by people and i
think it started when i was a kid and my
parents always said stay away from
just anyone adults like don't let them
near you don't let them touch you
and i think it's just now engraved in my
head that
i don't want to be touched by anyone
like i hate it i hate hugs unless i
haven't seen you in a while but
i don't like people coming up to me at
all and i think it got
extremely serious in high school when my
friend
my best friend i remember we were in our
living room and she said
have you ever been molested and i was
like what like why would you ask that
but it was because i hate it to be
touched like i hated her touching me
hugging me all of that
but that's my secret shhh
when i was in high school me and my
friends would
go run around and hang out down in
sewers and big culverts
and we called ourselves the sewer boys
we would crawl out from the drainage
pipes
and just end up being really stinky all
the time
so i'd have to say my biggest secret
would be
the fact that i'm 25 years old never
been kissed but i'm okay with it
[Music]
this isn't a very sketchy story but uh
my friends and i when we graduated high
school we
all hopped in one of my one of my
friends comes from a really big family
so he's got this huge van
and we all got in the van and drove down
this really busy road down in arizona
where we're from
and played the yellow light game it's
just a bunch of
like 10 dudes in the car and we all
played
any yellow light you saw we had to touch
the roof and the last one to touch the
roof had to
take an item of clothing off and we all
we all got nearly naked it was just
really stupid and funny because the car
got super
steamy and gross but it was a fun time
and a memory that i'll probably never
[Music]
forget
hi my secret is i farted in the sistine
chapel
[Music]
okay um
sometimes
i smell sharpies
oh that's it
so my secret is uh when i lived in l.a
i was taking a a long run and i was
outside like running by the airport on
the sidewalk and i had ran
like three miles out so i had to
run three miles to get back and i had to
[ __ ] really bad
so i [ __ ] on the side of the road
and used my sock to wipe my ass
[Music]
i secretly steal
rib eye steak from different
grocery stores around my
early 20s by hiding them under uh
water bottles that's my secret
uh my secret is whenever i was in middle
school um
i was pretty bad and i had like 19
referrals
um and my parents never find out about
it so
and they still don't know to this day
[Music]
i've been really indecisive about my
major for the past
two years but i act like i'm really
passionate about it
[Music]
i pretty much always feel anxious when i
go to visit my parents
my secret is that i'm still completely
in love with my ex-boyfriend
who cheated on me and i cheated back
but i don't know
people always tell me that i have my
life together and that they're super
proud of me and that i'm super strong
after everything that i've been through
and i honestly always really hate it
when people tell me that
um because despite everything that i've
been through
i just feel like it's always beaten me
and that like all they see is kind of
the outside perception like all the fake
facade that i put on
and that in reality i really just feel
like a
very passive participant in my own life
so my senior year of high school i was
dating this guy named
actually i'll kind of admit the name and
anyway we were out on a date we were at
this
kind of park or whatever it had just
gotten dark it's december sun goes down
pretty early
and uh anyway so this van pulls up
someone kind of starts walking towards
us
and then someone runs up behind and hits
him in the back of the head with a
baseball bat
and so it was like the first person that
i really ever like really liked and
you know the first person i did and
really the only person thus far
and uh he was taken to the hospital i
called 9-1-1 because i booked it
it kind of got as far away as possible
and
he was declared brain dead in the
hospital nine days later
and so that was kind of a great end to
my senior year of high school and then
um a really hard way to start like
college and everything that comes after
that with still trying to be a
functional member of society
my family's secret was i ran away from
home
because uh family problems since my mom
is an immigrant
it was a really hard for us to do
anything without uh
her getting in trouble for it and um one
day she had to go to court to see if
they were gonna send her back or not
hearing the news really broke me so i
decided to run away from home i ran away
for about
two days and they were out looking for
me for two days
she's still here um right now we're
still dealing with the problem
uh she might go later this year
actually so she's trying to come see me
like next weekend
before she has to go away because that's
a possibility
[Music]
hey everyone quick announcement i
decided to make a separate channel for
my podcast
it's going to be linked in the
description the new channel is called
hey stranger which as you know
is the name of my podcast if you enjoy
watching the video versions to my
podcast make sure to subscribe on there
that would mean a lot i tried really
hard not to make a second channel
because i just didn't want a second
channel but it really made
sense for the podcast to have its own
channel because
they're longer videos and i'm in them
and i'm usually not in my videos on here
so
i finally decided to make the new
channel for it i really hope you guys
will consider subscribing on there
again it's linked in the description and
yeah so
for my main channel i'm back to my
regular schedule which is i'll be
uploading every thursday on here
just like we used to i'm back for my
break and for my podcast
i'll be uploading every other tuesday so
basically every thursday on here
and every other tuesday i'll be posting
my podcast episodes
on the new channel that's linked in the
description and then of course you can
still find the audio versions of my
podcast on all the podcast platforms
and yeah that's pretty much it thank you
guys for everything
i love you all i'm happy to be back and
i'll see you next week
[Music]